das tor des nationalrates in teheran ist
ein beliebtes fotoobjekt für touristen
rena ist fremdenführerin
doch es ist lange her dass sie
ausländischen besuchern zuletzt das tor
zeigte denn die besucher kommen schon
lange nicht mehr mit verschiedenen
nebenjobs hält sich die 29-jährige über
wasser er ist die wirtschaftssanktionen
dann die korona pandemie die
tourismuswirtschaft brach zusammen
in iran gibt es mehr als 11.000
zugelassene fremdenführer
es hieß man würde uns darlehen geben
damit wir über die runden kommen aber
bis heute nach fast zwei jahren habe ich
immer noch kein darlehen bekommen
rainer ist enttäuscht von einer
regierung die es nicht geschafft hat
jungen leuten wie ihr eine perspektive
zu geben
sie fühlte sich allein gelassen auch in
der korona krise wie so viele andere im
land stürzte sie in ein loch bekam
depression
ich bin ein sehr extrovertierter und
sozialer männer aber ich war an einem
punkt an dem ich außer meiner firma wir
niemanden mehr sehen wollte
ich habe mich abgekapselt bin nicht mehr
rausgegangen wieder jemanden zu
vertrauen war sehr schwer für ghana
gehört zu den vielen millionen im iran
die frustriert und müde sind müde von
leeren versprechungen der politik und
die deshalb am freitag nicht zur wahl
gehen werden
eine wahl wäre dann korrekt wenn nicht
schon vorher fest stünde wäre unser
nächster präsident wird aber wir kennen
unseren nächsten präsidenten doch
lengers und ob ich nun wählen gehe oder
nicht wird daran nichts ändern
gemeint ist er amtierender
justizminister und der kandidat des
obersten religionsführers
ayatollah khamenei selbst machte reilly
zum chef einer mächtigen religiösen
stiftung später zum justizchef gemeinsam
bewohnten sie im vergangenen jahr den
tod general solle man dies den
us-präsident trump liquidieren ließ
ramelow drei sie vereint in ihrer trauer
um den general der revolutionsgarden und
vereint im hass auf den feind usa
doch damit sich irans wirtschaft aufholt
müssen die us sanktionen aufgehoben
werden und rossi weiß das geht nur wenn
er mit den amerikanern redet und sich
beide wieder an das atom abkommen halten
so gibt er sich in der fernsehdebatte
pragmatisch wir werden an dem abkommen
festhalten so wie sich regierungen an
verpflichtungen die sie eingegangen sind
gebunden fühlen sollten den jungen
unternehmer muhammad hat es geärgert wie
unverhohlen diesmal reisig organisiert
wird denn alle aussichtsreichen
gegenkandidaten hatte der wächterrat
vorher aussortiert
muhammad ist vorsichtig sagt er wolle
trotzdem wellen gehen versteckt seine
kritik hinter einem lächeln das ist
keine wirkliche wahl ich meine
nirgendwo auf der welt gibt es komplett
saubere wahl ich wünschte das was wir
haben wäre besser als das aber leider
ist es das noch
muhammad liebt sein land und dessen
kultur
er zeigt uns videos von den reisen
seiner kunden zu den nomaden völkern die
seine agentur organisiert er begleitet
kleine gruppen die einige tage mit den
familien auf wanderschaft gehen
[Musik]
muhammad will helfen diese kultur zu
erhalten startet vor vier jahren mit
seinem reiseunternehmen es läuft gut
dann aber beginnt der streit mit
us-präsident trump und dann die pandemie
wegen der korona pandemie wurden unsere
grenzen und für touristen geschlossen
es gab keine touristen visa mehr wir
mussten unser geschäft komplett zu
machen
er muss reagieren beginnt naturprodukte
der nomaden im internet zu verkaufen es
geht wieder aufwärts
der iraner sind dann krisen gewöhnt sagt
muhammad wir können uns arrangieren und
irgendwie arrangiert er sich auch mit
dieser präsidentschaftswahl vielleicht
stimme ich doch für jemanden der die
vorgänge ebenso ablehnt wie ich es tun
außerdem ist es ein zeichen dass ich die
hoffnung noch nicht ganz aufgegeben habe
dass man etwas verbessern kann
rainer dagegen bleibt haft für sie ist
es nur die inszenierung einer wahl alle
weiblichen bewerber seien ausgeschlossen
worden keiner der kandidaten habe ein
programm meint sie und die schuld an der
misere suchten sie stets bei den anderen
nie bei sich selbst wenn wir es nicht
schaffen die korona krise zu meistern
weil wir es erlauben dass die leute zum
iranischen neujahrsfest durch das land
reisen
dann ist doch nicht rand daran schuld
sondern wir selbst unser missmanagement
trägt die schuld daran
ich glaube die fehler liegen bei uns
selbst und ich habe keine hoffnung dass
irgendeiner dieser kandidaten etwas
besser
viele in iran haben keine hoffnung mehr
sind politikmüde sowie rainer und mit
dieser wahl werden es immer mehr
eine gefährliche entwicklung für das
land fast alle meine freunde haben iran
verlassen sagt rainer und auch ich werde
bald gehen